That's what it must have sounded like when
Belgian special police forces stormed Dounia
Depoorter's apartment on October 7th, 2018.
"They came in through here, forcefully pushed
me to the far end of the room.
When I opened the door, I was flung against
the piano and they twisted my hands behind
my back."
The singer was sheltering two unregistered
Sudanese refugees at the time -- this is where
they slept.
The Belgian police unit accused Depoorter
of people smuggling which left her speechless
"They told me: 'You are under arrest.
You no longer have any rights.
Be silent.'
The whole situation was one long violent ordeal.
I was wearing my pajamas.
A female police officer dressed me.
I couldn't even cry at that moment.
Only later."
Her computer and telephone were seized to
check whether she was working with Belgian
people smugglers.
The 45-year-old was handcuffed, and led out
of her home - while her neighbors were watching.
Where does human compassion end?
And where does people-smuggling begin?
We meet a lawyer who defends many Belgians
who acted just like Dounia Depoorter, and
are now accused of people trafficking.
He says the authorities are abusing their
power.
It is simply unacceptable that the police
and public prosecutors are going after ordinary
citizens, raiding their homes at 5 in the
morning.
That is an abuse of power.
There might be grounds to call in and question
citizens, which entails ringing their doorbell.
But not treating them as criminals.
This is Brussels' Park Maximilien, where refugees
flock who have no place to sleep, and don't
get regular meals.
We want to know how their life has changed
now that many Belgian citizens are too scared
to put them up for a few nights - because
of fear they are committing a crime.
The refugees want to remain anonymous.
Josef is from Eritrea.
He says he doesn't know where to sleep at
night, which makes braving the cold winter
temperatures even harder.
"How is your situation at the moment?
Where do you sleep at night?"
"Here in the park."
"Do you have a blanket?"
"Yes, I do.
We all sleep here.
My friends, too."
The Belgian parliament is deeply divided over
how to treat migrants.
Until recently, the right-wing nationalist
New Flemish Alliance party determined the
government’s tough stance on migrants, until
it quit the coalition in protest over the
UN migration pact.
What's their take on the current situation?
"I've got to do my duty...."
We requested an interview, too, but never
received a reply.
Dounia Depoorter was forced to spend 24 hours
in solitary confinement, until a judge ruled
she was innocent.
The ordeal has scarred her for life.
It will take a long time for her to regain
trust in people so that some day she may feel
strong enough to again help others.